okay let's start with an idea um curly
girl hair so you guys in trends did a
post about napped the natural hair
movement yeah that's a big big thing and
[Music]
mixed race mixed race and black women
and so talk a little bit about what was
in the report and then I'll tell you
sort of what I've seen separate from
that it sounds like you're more
interested in that you tell me what okay
alright so so I'll start with so my
sister-in-law got has super curly hair
and I've never seen Shawn he's Indian
I'm Indian and she's Indian and she's
got super curly hair and curly hair it
takes a lot of maintenance right like
gets humid boom it's frizzy and you have
like there's an episode of Friends where
Monica's hair is like an afro that that
happens or it's flat or you want to
straighten it or whatever it's a lot of
maintenance of curly hair and so she was
telling me she's like yeah I downloaded
this like I joined this thing I bought
this PDF that's called the curly girl
guide or something like that and it's
his method to fly taming your hair and
getting because I told her was like your
hair looks great nowadays it's like what
do you been doing and I just thought she
would say like oh I use this other
product she's like no there's like a 12
step process every time anybody with
curly hair cuz my man anywhere else so
my wife if you're I guess see there's my
wife's black she's halfway he's also not
here even if you're watching yeah so
he's half white half black and she buys
a lot of this stuff as well right and so
like there's a whole thing of like you
know when you go to sleep you need to
wrap your hair in a certain way to sort
of like whatever the oils blah blah and
so then and like some basics that you
just don't do so like she you know she
had curly her whole life but didn't know
oh I'm not supposed to use shampoo in
the same way that most people use
shampoo and so she was telling me about
some of these differences anyways
opportunity I was like I like these
businesses where you could put out
content and information that just helps
people and and then sort of on the back
end sell the kit that's like oh by the
way like if you just want to push a
button and get the solution I have the
kit that has all the [__] you need
because she spent hours researching all
the different products that like what is
the best version of this oil I'm
supposed to have what is the best
version
the shampoo for me and so anyways I
think there's an opportunity to do this
curly girl hair kit because there's a
huge number of women that have curly
hair the spend is in a multi billions
per year in the US for how this gets
treated and there is this natural hair
movement where it's less about doing
these really damaging things like
permanently straightening your hair or
you know weaves and whatnot like now
there's a sort of a natural hair
movement and so people need content like
education plus the tools this sort of
the hair care kit to take care of the
hair okay I love that Henry can you give
me a favor on a new tab type in reddit
curly hair so there's a whole subreddit
one of the ways I like to look at
validation and ideas for different
companies is I like to look at the
engagement and size of a particular
subreddit how many subscribers does the
subreddit have I can't read that from
here use that use that mic you got Henry
what are you doing that's pretty good I
think actually for a curly hair and in
particularly because reddit is mostly
men right and this is a woman's focused
curly hair subreddit with exactly so
great way to sort of validate the demand
and the community aspect to this where
people are sharing information
recommending products to each other the
other side of this is it photographs
great so you know before and after I
believe is the best ad that you can do
before which is a photo after which is a
better photo and you don't even need to
show your product you just need to show
whatever I took gave me this outcome I
was here now I'm there so my wife loves
this subreddit
okay so here's further validation okay
so particularly so I think that the
angle here is you have to go at Missa
tee or race-specific yeah so whether
it's Indian I have no idea if Asian
women suffer from this but if they do go
do that I know from firsthand experience
that mixed race women or whether they're
white and black or any other combination
suffer from this as well right and
further validation is Fenty Rihanna has
that brand that sold to the Louie
Vuitton company or was it called El LVMH
LVMH they and you could read about the
deal I think it was valued at 800
million dollars and her a lot of her
thing is towards
yeah mixed races and then another idea
here and everyone knows about this woman
but Kayla it's new
it seems this thing it's it's yes what's
her app this is your wife doesn't why do
I have does it yeah I sound like an
idiot cuz I'm a guy and I don't pay
attention yeah this whole segment is
like Bros trying to talk about you know
products they don't understand but I'm
fascinated I'm interested I'm trying and
everyone loves to try so Kayla's thing I
heard that's a hundred million dollar of
your company it is the fitness app
itself that's like crazy and it was just
built off her Instagram following so
that's crazy i management started with
she started with the same thing beach
but the bikini body guide I think was
her content that she just put out yeah
and then was PDF and a PDF have got
circulated everywhere and basically she
allowed there like paid PDF to get
bootlegged and just shared everywhere
and what that did was it just gave her
tons of awareness tons of marketing and
and then she launched the app which you
couldn't bootleg and you had to pay for
and then BOOM and the most interesting
part about her thing was she so she's
like mainstream popular and typically
when things are mainstream popular maybe
sometimes like people who think they're
cool can think it's kind of lame and
Sarah's a Ivy league-educated
New Yorker and she was like oh I love
this PDF right so she has access to all
types of interesting things and she
still used it and I and I thought that
was amazing that people really respected
and liked it yeah she comes across very
well if you've ever seen her content
she's not like she's not hateable like I
know that's cool oh and last thing diva
curl there have you heard of diva curl
bat no another mixed race shampoo maybe
it's for black women but or maybe I
don't know what the I figured if it's
black women or mixed race woman that's
what we use for shampoo and it was quiet
for acquired for a quarter of a billion
nice and there's some things on the
opposite side like Tristan Walker who
was I think either the co-founder or
first employee of Foursquare left to
start his own a frontier
african-american men's skin care product
company Walker brands Walker brands
where it was like you know shaving stuff
because you know the hair is different
its course it's gonna the traditional
shaving gear was causing problems and
didn't work out went under and that kind
of brings me to I don't know why it went
under exactly I don't know if it was
like
just raise too much money and [__]
everything up
[Music]